اهلا بك
سيد حاتم كريم الفلاحي اسالك عن ما
شاهدناه قبل قليل هذه الصور لاطلاق
الصواريخ كيف بعد مرور كل هذه الفتره
والتواجد الاسرائيلي جوا وبحرا وكذلك برا
من خلال وجود القوات الاسرائ داخل قطاع
غزه ومع ذلك مازال يتم اطلاق هذه الصواريخ
وبذه الكثافه كما شاهدنا في الفيديو قبل
قليل نعم تحيه لك ومشاهدي قناه الجزيره
نعم لا شك بان هذه الصواريخ تعطي دلالات
متعدده ومن ضمن هذه الدلالات دلالات
عسكريه ودلالات سياسيه الدلالات العسكريه
تنقسم الى قسمين القسم الاول يعطي دلاله
واضحه على ان فصائل المقاومه لازالت تمتلك
زمام المبادره والمبادله اطلاق الصواريخ
الى عمق الاراضي المحتله وهذه تعبر عن قوه
المقاومه وقدرتها على اداره الصراع
والمطول في هذا الصراع لاطول لاطول فتره
ممكنه يضاف الى ذلك بانه تعطي دلاله واضحه
على انه الكيان الصهيوني او الجيش
الصهيوني فشل في اسمكان هذه الصواريخ طوال
هذه المده على الرغم من امتلاكه للقدرات
العسكريه الكبيره بما فيها الطائرات
المسيره طائرات المراقبه والاستطلاع
والاقمار الصناعيه والطائرات الاستطلاع
البريطانيه والمساعدات الغربيه في هذا
الامر ولكنها فشلت في تحديد الاماكن التي
تنطلق منها هذه الصواريخ كما فشلت في وقف
هذه الصخ ارخ على الرغم من التوغل العسكري
الذي كان في شمال غزه والان في القطاع
الجنوبي باتجاه خان يونس اذا نحن نتكلم عن
فشل استخباري كامل في هذا المجال وفشل
عسكري في في استمكانه
الصواريخ يضاف الى ذلك بان فيها دلالات
سياسيه ترد على الاحتلال بانه التصريحات
التي تصدر من القيادات العسكريه والسياسيه
بالسيطره على قطاع غزه وان هناك عمل كبير
جدا تم تاديته هذه الصواريخ تعطي دلاله
واضحه على ان هذه التصريحات غير صحيحه وان
الامور في غزه ليس كما يصورها القاده
العسكريين او القاده السياسيين لذلك انا
اعتقد بان هذه الصواريخ لها دلالات كبيره
جدا وهي تعطي رساله واضحه بحيث عندما
يتكلم المتحدث الرسمي باسم الجيش قبل
الايام ويقول بانه بان المعركه قد تطول
وان حماس لازالت تمتلك قدرات عسكريه كبيره
ان اذا هو هذا اعتراف ضمني من قبل جيش
الاحتلال بان المقا وما لا زالت قويه
وتستطيع اداره الصراع لاطول فتره ممكنه
باشاره لطائرات المسيره ايضا في الخبر
العاجل سرايا القدس تقول سيطرنا على طائره
استطلاع صهيونيه من نوع ايفو ماكس 4 تي
تابعه لسلاح المشاه شرق خان يونس المقصود
بالسيطره هنا اسقاطها ثم الاستحواذ على
جسم المركبه ام له معنى اخر لفظ السيطره
باعتقادك نعم مساله السيطره على الطائرات
هذه القضيه يعني تكررت في فترات متعدده
يعني عندما نتكلم في عام 2004 2005 في
معركه الفلوجه الاولى والثانيه نفس الحاله
استطاع بعض المهندسين من التوصل الى اليه
الكترونيه يستطيع من خلالها انزال
الطائرات المسيره وبعضها تم استمكانه
الطائرات بحيث يمكن اخذ صوره من المعلومات
التي تبثها عن طريق القمر الصناعي الى
القياده العسكريه المتواجده في المنطقه
وبالتالي يمكن ان تكون حماس قد توصلت الى
نفس النتائج في مساله السيطره على هذه
الطائرات اما من خلال انزالها الكترونيا
او من خلال او من خلال استمكانه
التي ترسلها الى القمر الصناعي الذي
يرسلها بدوره الى القيادات العسكريه
وبالتالي هذه القضيه يعني نستطيع ان نقول
بانها سبق ان ان ان ان تم العمل بها في في
معارك سابقه ويمكن ان تكون هذه
التكنولوجيا او هذا العمل قد وصل الى حماس
وبالتالي هي تستطيع من ايقاف هذه الطائرات
واسقاطها بهذه الطريقه طبعا سرايا القدس
هي التي من سيطرت على هذه المسيره الان
اذهب بك شمالا العقيد حاتم لمحاوله فهم
تحديدا ما يجري في جباليه اكثر من 200 من
الشهداء سقطوا معارك ايضا مره اخرى ما
زالت مركزه في جباليه وتزداد شراسه من قبل
جيش الاحتلال طبعا من سقطوا من الشهداء هم
من
المدنيين هل سقوط كل هذا العدد هو ياتي
ضمن هذه العمليات المكثفه ام ان اسقاط
المدنيين وازهاق ارواحهم هو جزء من صلب
هذه المعركه وما يجري في جباليه
تحديدا نعم بدايه دعني اقول لا شك باني
عندما اتكلم عن القسام او اتكلم عن سرايا
القدس فانا اتكلم عن فصائل المقاومه الذين
هم الان في قارب واحد وبالتالي لا فرق بين
الفصائل في هذه القضيه اما في قضيه جباليه
فانا اعتقد بان هذه المنطقه هي منطقه
مكتظه بالسكان بشكل كبير جدا خصوصا وانه
المدنيين الذين نزحوا من هذه المناطق هم
باعداد قليله يعني وبالتالي نحن نتكلم عن
منطقه مكتظه جغرافيا مكتظه
سكانيا بالمدنيين يضاف الى ذلك بان هذه
المنطقه ذات تعقيدات جغرافيه كبيره يعني
الشوارع والحارات التي فيها الكثير منها
ضيقه ولا يمكن لاليات او المدرعات ان
تتقدم في هذه المناطق يضاف الى ذلك بانه
عندما يتم الان التركي على هذه المنطقه
لان تعتبر هذه المنطقه هي مفتاح لمناطق
كثيره مفتاح لمنطقه عمق غزه مفتاح لمنطقه
الشجاعيه منطقه مفتاح لمنطقه منطقه بيت
لاهيه وبالتالي تعتبر منطقه وسطيه و تعتبر
منطقه حاكمه الان عمليه قصف المدنيين لا
شك بانه من اللحظه الاولى بان قصف
المدنيين هو يعتبر جزء من استراتيجيه
الجيش الصهيوني في مس في اداره هذه الحرب
لذلك نرى بان الاعداد الكبيره التي وصلت
الى اكثر من 200000 شهيد والجرحى الذين
وصلوا الى اعداد كبيره جدا يعطي دلاله
واضحه على انه هو يصور جميع اعداء وجميع
هم حماس والجميع هم فصائل المقاومه
وبالتالي لا فرق له بين المدنيين والدليل
على هذا قصف المستشفيات والمدارس والكثير
من البنى التحتيه خلال الفتره الماضيه
الذي يقوم بقطع الماء وقطع الكهرباء اذا
لا يهمه امر المدنيين وبالتالي عمليه
القصف هي تاتي ضمن استراتيجيه الجيش جيش
الاحتلال في الدخول الى مدينه غزه فلذلك
هو يحاول الان التركيز على هذه المناطق من
خلال القصف لانه قد تكون هذه تمهيد
لعمليات مقبله يحاول القيام بها في هذه
المنطقه للسيطره عليها باعتبارها جزء من
المناطق التي لم يتم الدخول اليها او
التوغل فيها خلال الفتره الماضيه يتكلم
الجيش الاسرائيلي عن مراحل في هذه الحرب
بينما جرى ويجري في مناطق شمال غزه وما
يجري الان في جنوبها مصادر من الجيش الاص
تقول بان المعركه في خان يونس قد تتطلب
شهورا للقضاء على حباس كما يقول تقول هذه
المصادر من الجيش الاسرائيلي وبالتالي هل
نحن امام تكرار لنفس السيناريو العسكري
الذي جرى في الشمال يتم تنفيذه الان في
الجنوب ام هناك مرحله اخرى واختلاف فيما
يجري نعم في في مساله المرحله هم يتكلمون
الان هم في المرحله الثانيه يعني و عندما
جاء مستشار الامن القومي جاك سليفان الى
الى اسرائيل تكلم على انه يجب الخروج من
هذه المرحله والبدء بمرحله هي اقل كثافه
من المرحله السابقه ولكن هذا الكلام هو
نظري و وغير عملي لانه ما يجري على الارض
يختلف عن هذه التصريحات بشكل كبير جدا
يضاف الى هذا بان عندما نتكلم الان عن
المعارك احن نتكلم عن المرحله الثانيه
التي تعتبر هي مرحله حاسمه للطرفين وتكون
شديده وعنيفه على الطرفين وبالتالي نتكلم
عن مناطق تم التوغل فيها من قبل جيش
الاحتلال ومناطق يحتدم القتال عليها
ومناطق اخرى تسيطر عليها فصال المقاومه
لحد هذه اللحظه لذلك نرى انه ما يجري الان
في الشمال او ما يجري في الجنوب هو جزء من
عمليه من من استراتيجيه المرحله الثانيه
في عمليه التوغل والسيطره على هذه المناطق
من قبل قوات الاحتلال ولكن شك يبدو بانها
تواجه نعم حياكم الله العقيد الركن حاتم
كريم الفلاحي شكرا جزيلا لك